what is the purpose of life in the ball
uh yeah everyone has to have their own
answer to this question so my my answer
doesn't is not necessarily correct it's
just valid for me
uh it's not valid for you so what's
interesting is more to explore the
question uh than to
you know try and come up with an answer
to the question
um
you know i i couple gupta and i've
talked quite a bit about this and
the conclusion that i've sort of come to
for myself
is i'm not answering your question
directly i'm asking a little indirectly
is when i try to think about what i want
to do these days with my life and and
i'll be the first to admit that i have a
luxury that the rest of you don't or
many of you don't which is i have money
so i have a lot more options open to me
but i like to think that i would have
still thought this way even if i don't
have money
which is
when i think about what i should do with
my life
i kind of realize that
none of it is going to matter in the end
in fact one good mental construct
um
if everyone could stop with the
questions for a sec one good mental
construct is that
i think that everything i do in my life
is going to be a failure
everything i do is going to be a failure
and and i'm being deliberately
provocative because i'm trying to catch
your attention to deeply think about
this
the reason everything i do is going to
be a failure is one is on the material
level on the physical level i'm going to
die and when i die i won't care i've
been under general anesthesia i've you
know there was life before what was life
like before i was born i just didn't
care
in those situations you don't care so
when you die you don't care about
anything anymore so in that sense
everything you're accomplished you don't
take anything with you it's a failure
there's a second sense in which it's all
guaranteed to fail which is even if you
believe in ideas and memes and progeny
and legacy
well eventually the earth will
fade away and after that the solar
system will fade away and after that the
galaxy will fade away and then the
universe will end so nothing is forever
nothing is permanent so everything goes
to zero eventually so there's that sense
of failure and there's a third way of
realizing that everything you do is
destined to fail which is just look at
your own experience every time you do
anything and you succeed you're really
happy about it and then a year later
you're back to where you started
sometimes even a day later but best case
a year later you're mentally back to
where you started
the same way if you
fail to do something or something goes
poorly for you you're miserable and
unhappy but within a few months or a
year you're back to your previous state
mentally
so
even when you succeed
you bank that success right away and you
essentially fail so everything i do in
my life
is guaranteed to fail so now what should
i do with my life and the answer is
only what i really want to do
for its own sake and that's the
definition of art so whether it's
business whether it's exercise whether
it's
romance whether it's friendship whatever
you're doing
i think the meaning of life is to do it
for its own sake it's to just do it
because you love living it there is no
meaning beyond that and ironically when
you do things for their own sake
that's when you create your best work
that's when it's art that's when it's uh
you know that's when you create
uh your
that's when you're gonna that's when
you're gonna
do your finest work and so even if
you're trying to make money you'll
actually be the most successful the year
in which i
sort of generated the most wealth for
myself even though it hasn't paid out
yet i can tell just in terms of like i
accomplished the most i created the most
value
on an economic basis was actually also
the year in which i worked at least hard
but it was the year in which i cared the
least about the future it's where i was
mostly just doing things for the sheer
fun of it where i was basically telling
people i'm retired i'm not working and
then i had the time
to put into whatever was highest value
in front of me and by doing it for its
own sake i did it at its best
so
i don't know if that answers your
questions about meaning life but that is
one way in which i think about it there
are other frames that i use there's
probably about 10 different frames that
i'm using at all times to think about my
life and but that is a recent and
powerful one
maybe you think no life isn't that hard
it's like
not only is it that hard it's even
harder than you think
so
you're going to be tested that's for
sure and if you have a sustaining
meaning then
there's there's well nietzsche said
himself
he who has a why can bear any how
why would you look in the darkest places
because in the darkest places you could
find what still shines
if it can shine in the darkest places
then you know it's a real light
and so you look at things you don't want
to look at you have to look at the
things you don't want to look at well
why do meaningful things
well first of all what is meaning
but then why do meaningful things and
the answer is well because life is
suffering
and malevolence
it's inerratical at its core
it's like that will take you out
make no mistake about it
you need something to you need to be
armed with virtue in order to
for that not to turn into hell
really
you really need that
ubantu is another polynesian word i
wanted to share with you
if you find your why you will always
find your how ubantu is your reason for
being
the bigger the why
the more powerful the how
if there is no consequence to your why
you will not have good solutions
if your why is extraordinarily large you
will be more creative than will than any
problem can overwhelm so let me give you
a thought experiment
there aren't too many of us who would
run into a burning building for a few
hundred dollars
some of you may run into a burning
building for a million dollars
if you have children and your children
are in that building and it requires you
to put yourself at risk in order to save
their souls
most of us would run without hesitation
into that building when you understand
your why you will find your how it's
understand the contextualization and
your source of strength the difference
between struggle and suffering is
meaning
if you have profound meaning in it it's
just a struggle you will power through
if it has no meaning you will suffer and
often you will break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you